Some of the most interesting studies
near death and out of body experiences
were run by the air force,
right?
As airplanes got faster and faster and
faster over the past 20 years,
right?
Pilots kept flying themselves into g
lock,
gravity induced loss of consciousness.
Right?
And they kept crashing.
So a guy named James winner was,
was a guy kind of charged with solving
this problem.
And what he did is down in Texas,
he spun like a thousand pilots in a
giant centrifuge into g lock.
Right?
And as he was doing it,
he noticed something interesting.
She locked means you pass out and if
you've experienced it,
what actually happens is your vision
forms into a tunnel.
It looks like if you're,
if you're watching it,
it looks like an old television set
turning off where it goes down into one
point and then disappears.
Right?
So it looks experientially a lot like
you're walking down a long dark tunnel,
which is kind of one of the classic near
death experience.
A phenomenon.
What he discovered along the way is that
as he started spitting people towards g
lock,
kind of the longer he spun them,
people started reporting out of body
experiences and after they were out of
their body,
if he kept spitting them,
it would turn into a near death
experience.
Right?
So he's the person that he was,
air force is the person,
the US Air Force discovered that outer
body experiences in near death
experiences are actually on the same
continuum there.
They're part of the same chain of effect
and a lot of it has to do with the right
temporal lobe.
There's other things going on as well.
And there are of course certain
mysteries,
right?
There are unsolved things in near death
experiences.
We've got lots and lots and lots of
research that shows people report things
when they were supposedly dead that they
should not have known about at all.
So there are people who died on
operating tables,
right in research.
Studies came back,
were brought back.
They had near death experiences,
and while they were dead,
the nurse would take their glasses off
and put it in a drawer,
and later when everybody was running
around looking around for their glasses,
the person who was on the operating
table at the time,
the patient who was dead at the time
said,
oh yeah,
they're in the bottom drawer over there.
And this is a Pimm's Bon Llama Lamo
study that was actually done in the
Netherlands.
This is where that actually happened.
But there's a lots and lots of
experiences like that.
So somewhere along the line,
information is getting through,
right?
We don't know that yet.
That's still the mystery.
But a lot of the other stuff,
we understand the biology behind it now.